they are the covid generation
this the finale of their stop-start
education
i did better on further masters
but for a third year running the brown
envelopes contained better grades than
the pre-pandemic era
online learning was absolutely hell for
me it didn't work out for me at all
but once i got back in the classroom
everything kind of clicked and i
improved a lot of students so i'm very
happy with how far i've come it feels
amazing i like all the effort you put in
and seeing the results pay off i'm so
happy i can't even speak
my mom she was so proud because she knew
i was stressing out about it for the
past week so i just called her she just
screamed in my ear i was like yeah
that's me
[Music]
because of covert disruption students
received extra help such as advanced
site of exam topics here at mossborne
academy in hackney the school added an
additional school hour each day for year
13.
their learning curve the trajectory has
been far far steeper but they've
benefited from that
how have they benefited from that
they've benefited from it in that they
realize that
they have they can be master of their
own destiny
but the previous two years a level crop
had unorthodox assessments graded by
their teachers as a result across the uk
they did better
this year's cohort are one of the most
disrupted by covid they didn't get to
sit their gcses they didn't get the
advantage of the potentially more
generous teacher assessed grades and it
was always anticipated that examiners
this year would have to unwind the great
inflation of the last two years
hence this year there were sixty
thousand fewer a's and a stars than last
year
we always had a plan that we wanted to
get the grades back towards the kind of
levels that we saw pre pandemic we've
taken a big step in that right direction
they are still a little bit higher than
they were in 2019 but they are down on
on last year and that's right and proper
but what we've also seen is a
two-thirds of students getting their
first or reserve place at university and
that is great
for universities and employers it's that
bit harder to compare students from
different years and the post-pandemic
grade reset is expected to continue
downwards for two more years while the
university college admissions service
ucas says competition for the top
courses gets more competitive
this year we've seen more rates 18 year
olds in the population we've seen more
demand than ever from those 18 year olds
so i think from here on in and this will
increase year on year it does get
slightly more competitive at those
really competitive courses and
institutions
there are fewer students who didn't get
a university place compared to 2019 but
for those now searching there's also a
thousand fewer courses with available
places at the top universities compared
with last year and for some their future
will be determined by whatever they can
find on the ucas website jason farrell
sky news